[Music]
[Music]
yeah I'm yells Hannibal Burres we got
another episode
that's Tony trim on the drums
and all their men we have a special
guest the director of 1013 yeah Hamza
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah yeah
chef Tom's equal sup man hey man that's
my first theremin yeah
that's it's trippy I don't know if I
really have the hang of it yet is easy
you just got it about the nitrogen's
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah that's what our show is
I'll just keep now you fill it man I'm
good man I'm good man I just got in town
again and my whole family just got here
so I'm already beat it's up tense I'm a
little bit tense I got my father coming
in from Florida got my mother coming in
from Iowa got my sister and her husband
coming in from Wisconsin the whole
country is coming in for this premiere
nice nice we got we got a tawny media
pass tickets well he's coming to when
this Lee was just gonna come to the
movie but we were talking to Jake we
what should we do for the carpet he's
like first of all gotta get him doing
carpet well we haven't quite figured out
the angle now I want to work I kind of
wanted to workshop this with you because
you're yeah yeah and I know you got good
ideas you - uple of episodes of broad
city that's right yes so so so you know
what people like I try I try I mean I
can you make this mobile can you bring
the theremin that's the thing the
theremin is not battery-powered so we
can't bring the theremin we have plugs
out there though yeah so we deal with
cameras and stuff yeah like just - all
you need an extension cord right this
thing takes batteries I can bring this
I think if you could roll this down the
red carpet yeah with a big PA speaker I
think that would be amazing
no this thing's got a speaker built-in
so I think whenever someone asks
hannibal about what has to be honest
where you can carry it but like to be
somebody holding it for me yeah I need a
Behrman holder maybe I have my stunt
double from last year no reason to plug
it in everywhere so I have to bring my
own power source one extension cord or
just a car battery yeah this thing we're
gonna car battery so just pulling around
a general gas-powered generator yeah
yeah we came up with the high production
ideas more than 24 hours before there's
still time
yeah no problem I know some guys with
generators yes do it first feature film
times it yeah first Congrats you've
lived with this everyday well not every
day but a lot of the days pretty much
every day every day much every day for
over a year it's crazy yeah you never
think you're gonna hear the same jokes
for two years about tag yeah but then
you do cuz you have to replay it and
yeah we caught it yeah it was it was
like 26 weeks of editing or something
like that 26 weeks yeah and that's a
little under seven months yeah yeah so
you're involved so you did the editing
as well are you directing the editing I
dragged a director the editing I just
sat on a couch eating
that was yeah exactly that one right
there
no stop I would just snap like up like
that okay actually you the first well no
we had Kevin Smith Don Smith yes yep was
you the first director that I've worked
with that we've had on the show so I got
a lot questions what was the prep
process like what is prepping for a
movie like well it was it was 10 weeks
in Atlanta before just a straight prep
of just you know where there were 78
locations on this movie I don't know if
you noticed somebody it sets really but
yeah a lot of location so and s is that
above average
that's pretty high for a comedy yeah so
a lot of that time you're just running
around in a van and the heat looking at
different churches different basements I
mean every place that we went I'd looked
at like 10 other places o matic
okay pick what work best so but it's
kind of an action film too right yeah
you dad you have to have the right
amount of space to do some stunts huh
yeah you know the first week we were in
that basement and it was enormous again
really tell but there's so much there's
so much [ __ ] in there there's I don't
know if you remember how hot it was but
that first day because it was an action
seekers were shooting that super slow-mo
we had like 10 20 K lights which are so
hot that I walked in there in all the
windows in the church shattered because
it was shattered from the heat of the
lights what yeah all these play glass
like eight plate glass windows above the
church just shattered from the heat of
the lights
Wow and then we and then we had to make
you run around you luckily had to sit in
the hall eating chips oh you didn't have
to do all that see sit down yeah it's
like ham and Renner and and a door just
running around and it was it was like
there were like clouds steam clouds on
the ceiling at that place because it was
so hot in there Atlanta got weirdly hot
and humid and with rain for a week at a
time with us every day yeah rain yeah
with no
variance so lots of locations I didn't
know that about the location scouting
process that you look at in of them yeah
well yeah and the guys go out the
production designer goes out before me
it looks even more so now I'm looking at
photos the spin is the selects yeah
that's that's what they decide to take
me to Wow and then we pick based on yeah
like can we do the action sequence there
does it look all right you know how I
was gonna look at night the day you know
you're gonna do all this stuff so it's a
lot of that a lot of like local casting
there's a lot just breaking down shot
listing the whole movie figuring out how
you know we had like six to ten actors
and every scene so I got to figure out
how the hell I'm gonna shoot that that's
a lot of shots
it is about sighs yeah it's remember the
first thing you said to me day one you
said Friday City you were my favorite
director you do like two takes and then
we go home yeah yeah yeah I'm sick
that's gonna be a quick movie shoot max
have got it moving
it's a crazy different process I mean
that's usually how I work but you know
you have so many people yeah even here
like now I get into the thing we're like
just sitting around the four of us here
I start to think about how quickly I can
shoot this conversation because I mean
camera here came there you know
everywhere you're looking to two shots
so you're directing your life yeah I
have so much anxiety so why okay too
much light right there but we lit this
is we had a real production going on
ring lights everywhere yeah yeah it
should all work like this would be what
fast
[Laughter]
now it is a different muscle to develop
just the repetition of and just the the
pace of movies yeah cuz I was looking at
the other actors I yeah you do only you
only act that's crazy it's tough it's a
marathon right yeah but the finished
product obviously is is rewarding when
you see it all together is like okay we
did that a bunch of times but it worked
out yeah how does it feel to you because
for me you know I've thought about it so
much like planning in a prep yeah
breaking it down like I start to forget
about you know just the experience of it
you know because I've looked at so many
times I can't tell flows I have to watch
it with an audience just see if jokes
are landing stuff like that you know
because you know you're sitting there
thinking in your own head oh this is
this is gonna work this is gonna play
it's how much time you need to set up
the trip whatever you have a story but
it's hard I see it it's like I see all
the puzzle pieces still I can't see the
whole well I was able to I had the
chance to disconnect from it for a bit
you have to live with it before it was
you know before we were actually working
on it you were doing that prep and then
we're working on it then editing and
test screens so you have to really be
fully immersed which I imagine there's a
lot where I've got kind of a few months
break from it with shoots hangs every
tag tag tag every day that is like six
seven months ya know that cuz you just
saw it like the other night for the
first time all together how many times
have you watched it you think you know
I've been trying to figure that out I
mean over over a hundred times which is
more than anyone should ever watch
you know it's like the end of Clockwork
Orange you know where he holds his eyes
open they forces that's how I feel about
it
like whenever I watch it with the
audience they're having a good time I'm
like oh okay this is a fun movie but for
me I'm like I don't know I have no idea
I can't even hear the words you know
it's like when you repeat the you know
some word too many times like I don't
even understand the meaning anymore
the screening went well and I enjoyed it
but he was still like now for the
premiere I'm thinking okay I'm gonna
step out every you know I will step out
for a bit I mean I think it'd be fun to
watch people's reactions but watching
yourself even if it's even if it's good
is still rough watching yourself yeah I
feel the same way and it's not me
physically on camera but I feel like the
movie it's like it's a weird mirror like
I hate like I'm never gonna listen to
this because I hate hearing my own voice
but I feel the same way that the movie
like there's enough of my personality in
there not like this is this is too close
to home I need do you ever let your
actors watch the take after they do it
oh yeah sure you do
just some directors don't write some
directors aren't they like I should
trust the process the weird thing about
being a director is you don't ever get
to hang out with other directors it's a
lonely job so you don't see how other
people work very often but I've heard
that yeah I've heard that some guys
girls don't want to show the takes don't
want to get in the actors heads yeah
yeah and I was nervous about it at first
too because the same thing like
sometimes you just don't like looking at
yourself you can't have a but do you
take into consideration if the actors
like you know I didn't like to take but
you really like that take do it yeah I
definitely have had that conversation
yeah but do you have to cut them off and
be like amen
just trust me [ __ ] don't exactly
what I say well for me when I do watch
playback on a take is good cuz I'm not a
great actor so sometime I'm not doing
I'm thinking I'm expressing or conveying
something that I totally am NOT yeah I'm
showing emotion and I look at the tape
oh no I'm dead in the eyes right there
break it up a little bit so I like
watching cuz it just shows me oh I can
move I can show more movement here or do
little small adjustments to the
performance yeah it's true sometimes you
I'm when I'm giving direction or notes
or whatever I forget you can't really
you know if you're not seeing the
monitor you don't know exactly what the
reading or not and you can't tell what
shot you're in if you're standing there
so sometimes it just helps to be like
you know to say okay take a look at this
one I needed more more of this thing or
the other thing because I'm not seeing
that part and you know some of us that's
helpful with these would with our cast
like no one was no one was crazy and
would have gotten to in their heads and
I think yeah I mean like are you one of
those directors that's like no [ __ ]
straight to the player you more like I'm
open to suggestions what do you get I'm
very chill I was very open to everything
you know because a lot of the scenes we
were trying to find the the real jokes
you know the weird thing is like
especially with a movie like this you
know none of its a big cast everyone's
playing old friends all these guys
didn't know each other you know you know
before they've showed up on the first
day or the first week so it had like it
had to be organic I had to change
because I wanted people's real
personalities in the movie so it didn't
feel like I was prescribing oh you're
the stone or you're this guy or whatever
I Hannibal's character changed immensely
I think like even two weeks before we
shot just cuz I trying to make make it
feel right for everyone's style of
comedy and you know their voice you know
Jake's character was never exactly that
he was just sort of a stoner but Jake
came in as he's this sort of you know
brusque skeptic nihilist he's sort of
angry at everything but sort of loving
in the same way of what's making it
makes him really funny and try to put
that into that character so yeah I try
to just keep it open so all these
characters did you have them in mind for
or was that a process to figure out who
was gonna be who or did you already like
know like okay Hannibal's this guy this
guy is this guy it was a it was a it was
a long process trying to figure it out
and I I kind of like I didn't really
know the real guys until we got
started because I didn't want to get in
touch with him and then the whole movie
fell apart and I ruin their lives so I
kind of kept them at arm's distance and
then brought them in once I knew
everything was okay yeah so I base it
more on like my group of friends growing
up and I I just met with people on a new
Hannibal I knew Jake I knew John Hamm
for a long time I just met Runner an IDI
through this but in Island Annabelle and
Leslie but I kind of wanted people that
felt like they I don't know it's you
know you meet people just like when
you're hanging out you're like oh that's
somebody I could hang out with be
friends with they feel like an old
friend of mine I start make it I knew
everyone was funny so I just wanted to
make choices where it felt like a real
group that kind of feel like my group of
friends people I would like to spend
three months in Atlanta heat with and
that try to get to a point we're all
killed each other so that was through
the process yeah we went to a strip club
in Atlanta
I don't describe the Clermont lounge as
a strip club that's a house of oddities
yeah but no we - it's up peaches which
is is a div' spot okay and I've been
there one one other time at this point
is early and shoot it and I almost got
into you had you have a vigil strip club
like that I I've never been to a strip
club in Atlanta that was my fears and
only one I have been to Clermont either
and I was like I always heard like you
gotta go to strip clubs in Atlanta yeah
like part of the scenes we lived right
around the corner from there somehow it
was under construction or something no
yeah Claire mine was under construction
we live like a block from there when
we're seeing but we went yeah we went to
this place peaches all I remember is it
was so bright inside that which is not
as those peaches bright you sure it was
it was like they had stadium lights
inside that place we just I don't why
having a strip how you see every detail
every stretch mark
I'm stayin I almost got into it with the
DJ what happened well really I'm you
know I'm I don't remember this so I was
I was pretty faded and I was close to
the stage tiffen the dancer like in I
was in you know what I fade it like
throwing money a few people and
Hannibal's disappeared into the end of
the mix I just he was gone
sounds about right throwing money just
really in the zone and the DJ says lana
DJ's are super vocal about yeah pay that
[ __ ] throw that money like they hype up
you to spend more money on the dances
because they get tipped by the desks and
so and at one point he's like yeah money
throw money and I said jokingly I say
hey shut up man and he say what and then
he leaves DS a blown up see I see him
leaving the DJ booth oh my all he thinks
I was seeing so I I meet him and say
like hey man lizard where are you from
Chicago
Mike shuts out in the building but at
first he was like yo what the [ __ ] you
just say yeah yo I was kidding you were
kidding on the mic telling me to throw
the money I was saying shut up I guess
he found out I was from out of town and
he accepted it but I like he turn that
back around back into hyping you back up
yeah you mean did you spend more money
after that all right shall I give that
money up now yeah that's cool yes it was
so bright in there that's all I remember
I don't remember it being that brighten
it but you might maybe it was all so
early we weren't there like 7 p.m.
[Laughter]
[Music]
I was a hell of a day that was a it was
like a Sunday afternoon I just remember
I was going down the coffee shop to do
some work and you're coming up the
stairs with some Don Julio and that was
so first feature yeah how'd you booked
the gig
you know I I had a I had a short film at
Sundance like five or six years ago and
right after that gotten the agent and
all this stuff and started getting all
these features and I sold a couple
pitches early on and thought I was hot
[ __ ] I was like all right I'm taking
over this town
and then I I realized that that's sort
of what happens to everybody you just
you get attached to things and then they
never happened and then I was just
working for like two years like every
day on these movies that we're never
gonna get made and I didn't understand
they were never gonna you directed
movies do I just like working in
development developing the scripts like
yeah cuz I was looking at Ryan DB you're
like a Renaissance guy you had like
writing credits producing credits
directing greedy did like everything huh
well I'm from I'm from Iowa and it was a
hard thing to like hard thing to do to
call myself a director I was felt like
I'm from a tiny town middle of nowhere
sort of yeah and so I felt like I need a
name of the town Cedar Rapids Cedar
Rapids
okay Cedar Rapids penguins how many
penguins
I've been I haven't but yeah I'm aware
of Cedar Rapids see
I need more of that yes I mean it's it's
the second-largest city in in Iowa but
it's a hundred and twenty five thousand
people or something like that no it's
big for Iowa and small isn't a college
town or now it colleges in Iowa City in
a name so University of Iowa's you're
like 30 minutes away there's a little
couple little colleges there but there's
like a factory wasn't ed Helms in a
movie called cedar it was yeah I talked
to Ed about that yeah and the funny
thing about that is that they were gonna
shoot in my hometown everyone's very
excited that in Helms is gonna come to
see Robin and shoot this movie and then
the they caught the head of the Iowa
Film Commission embezzling money from
all the productions that they were
shooting or something like that and so
they shut down all the filming and the
tax credits in all of Iowa an they had
to shoot it outside Cedar Rapids
they shot Grand Rapids which is
ironically annoying but yeah it was a
real letdown it's really it could have
been our it was our claim to fame as a
city one person one person one person's
greed ruined a city's chance to sign
what if you were resident of Cedar
Rapids full of hope for dreams and
vision for your city on the big screen
and these sisters of one-minute
extension evil way what would you do
oh gee food
[Music]
so what's the what's the application
process for I like it sounds like
getting a job McDuck you have to still I
mean I know maybe it varies for some but
you have to present something or you say
this would be my take on this yeah yeah
so yeah get you get a script from your
agents and I don't know what baloney
they've gone through before that you
know they send my work to the studio
guys or whatever in this case I guy I'd
known a couple of the guys at new line
since for like seven or eight years
since we were all a bit younger and
broke and they were assistants and we
were always talked about making a movie
together and we've never really found a
script that uh that worked and but I've
been in there talking to him about a
bunch of stuff and then I got this and I
say I saw this thing you get the script
I got this one it was called tag and I
refused to read it I had this good for
like weeks and I was like I'm not
waiting not about it I was like what
yeah exactly
yeah I think that's what everyone's
reactions gonna be now is really like
why because the movies pretty good I
mean it's it's a still about tag but I
think people are gonna be like this is a
pretty good movie for a movie about time
yeah they've been playing the [ __ ] out
that trailer and they're making it looks
good it looks good I haven't seen it yet
but I'm gonna see it tomorrow so yeah
yeah it's good it's funny it's really
sweet it's like a it's a funny movie
it's also like really wholesome and in
loving which is I think I'm really proud
of but it's not what I expected when I
got this thing called tag I'm sure you
had the same experience but yeah III
like had it sitting there I was like I'm
not there's no way I know that there's a
stack of papers here with tag and the
cover but I refused to open the stack of
papers thing it took you weeks to get to
it I've got to it yeah finally my my my
agent literally sent me you know in all
caps just saying just read
[ __ ] script and I did I was I was up
I go on this vacation with my high
school friends from Chicago and in Iowa
up to this little lake and in Canada and
it was like if I go up there every year
and it's the first year none of them
come because you know we're old and they
have kids and when a guy his older
brother died had a heart attack so he
was down in Oklahoma City visiting him
and all kinds of [ __ ] you know so I was
up there just with my family and my
thoughts and I was like all right I'll
read this goddamn thing and I got pretty
much all be honest I got pretty
emotional at the end because it is about
getting older you can't see your friends
as much because they've moved away
people get sick people get have kids you
know it's just it's it's logistically
more difficult than it seems just to
stay connected to to your roots and and
you know there were there was a lot of
work to be done on the script but like
it's not often you get a comedy that
like even gets that place or even has a
point most of them just some dumb
premise that doesn't doesn't really have
anything to say so I got it to it like
you know and and then you go through
this whole process where you you come in
for initial meeting with like two guys
and you're like well and they were like
what's your take you say I think this
movie is all about all about how you
need to stay connected your friends and
that's the core of it and all of our
comedy should come from that you kind of
you find you find some core and
obviously what you're doing and I didn't
realize this until it even after I
finished the movie you like whatever
you're saying isn't just [ __ ] fluff
to get the job it's actually you're
telling them what you're gonna do and
once you get started you don't have
anything to go for him except okay this
and I'm what I told them is this is a
love letter to my my friends that's what
I want to make I I love my my buddies I
grew up with since I was kid this is a
movie I want to do that whatever we do
comedic Lee I want music cast and
whatever I want wanted to be people
jokes
music tone that they'll respect ya and
that's that's that's what I try to keep
is my foundation like every day so we
know so
so we know that it's based on a true
story how close did you stay to the
actual true story as obviously it's a
rendition of you and your friends but
how like as far as the true story like
how how much of it is well a lot of a
lot of it sounds like [ __ ] that's
what I wanted to hear yeah
the thing about I think about me a
19-minute story
this is something's going on almost 40
years with these guys and it doesn't
really have a beginning a middle of men
you know they started it they've gone
through a lot of struggles
this thing has kept them together but
there's not necessarily any like
untouchable guy like jeremy renner
they've been chasing they need to get
for X Y Z so that that was the big thing
that's fiction and honestly the the
Jeremy Renner character doesn't exist in
life and that was sort of something that
just gave it a goal and then it was
really the guy that had drifted away and
was sort of felt lonely felt
disconnected from them because he was so
good at it was so that was that was
fictionalized but like there are aspects
of all of that all those kinds of things
in each of them and now I think talk to
them you know there's you know there are
certain pieces of the movie they're
specific like the tagging at the funeral
and Italian during the delivery room and
and the guy dressing up as a woman like
specific tag all right let's not give up
too much okay yeah we'll wait we'll wait
and we'll we'll drop that you know that
one of the real guys is a Catholic
priest mmm so I really wanted to make
one of the characters of Catholic priest
but the the Catholic Church refused to
have any representation or likeness of
him in an r-rated comedy okay this guy
of this guy yeah so wait hey what just
say no no you can't wear that what I
could say that no priest it's not like
NBA jerseys
hope had to step in no no you can't use
on about Jesus own the rights to Jesus I
think you could make that argument with
them no we were actually gonna put you
know we come company out of the movie
and there's there's footage and photos
of them that's actually what they say
that they refused but we also just felt
like if we couldn't reference that
directly it was too crazy right just to
put a priest in a movie called tag so
it's sort of part parcel so the Catholic
Church the Catholic Church said no but
the funniest thing is that like after we
finished the movie and I met the real
guys and we got along they called father
Sean and told him you know they don't
even seen the movie but they were like
we really like Jeff we met the guys we
saw some of the shoot we feel like he
really should be a part of this and so
there's Catholic priests in Montana
called me and and he's like Jeff what
should I do
I really this is a big this is like the
people I love most of my life what
should I do
should I put confessed to me all the
time no I'm confessing to you yes Father
I don't know how to give you guidance 20
Hail Mary yeah no I sent him a movie so
he he's the only one of the real guys
that's seen the full movie and he loved
it and it's funny cuz he's like a huge
comedy nerd so he knew you he's like
what he knew like he was like quoting me
lines from Caddyshack and all these
other movies and and I was like oh god I
this is a lot to live up to it I get God
and and a comedy nerd one person so but
I sent it to him he watched it like
almost two hours later like the runt end
of the movie he emailed me said I'm in I
love it
so that was pretty cool I feel like me
even though it's a lot of [ __ ] I
feel like we did whatever we happened to
do it to your spirit yeah the Holy
Spirit the Holy Spirit
all right I like what you did there tell
me what God's on our side so we got an
ongoing joke it's only partially a joke
with me well I tried to when I was in
Atlanta and people ask me what are you
doing in Atlanta I say working on a
movie they said what's the name of the
movie and I would say tag and they would
kind of wait for me to say something
else afterwards and so you know I'm one
with my stand-up if the joke doesn't
work
I would like to dig in and find what
else is there so I had suggested that
the movie should be called tag tag tag
is gonna call tag you might as well lean
into it tag tag that we focus grouping
this on you right now okay tag tag you
can put it is that for a trilogy
oh is it tag tag oh I just call it that
yeah they call it tag I'll call it tag
tag tag that's gonna be my red carpet
thing you could do a tag tag tag tag tag
tag tag tag tag tag tag I like it as it
is just tag tag tag tag - tag - tag -
tag - tag tag
[Music]
santé tag tag tag - tag died back it's
like
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah so here's a question how far did
you get into the movie before Jeremy
broke both of his arm here it is here it
is do you know the answer this question
yet I don't know the answer this
question was at three three days not
even three days two and a half days into
the movie so did you have to delay
production no we did not we not it was
well the whole that whole week was crazy
for variety reasons it was Thunder
snoring I don't know if you remember
this was thunderstorm day 1 and day 2 so
we had to shut down in Atlanta you have
to shut down for half an hour every time
there's a lightning strike within six
miles of set you know so the by the time
we got to day two we'd shut down for a
total of six and a half hours for more
than half of the day we'd lost just from
weather so that and then Jon Hamm was
also flying to London mid week for the
baby driver oh yeah
so and we're doing the biggest basically
the biggest comedy set-piece and the
biggest action set piece in the movie
that week yeah so it was it was already
tough so day three sort of on a flip
yeah Jeremy broke both his arms chain of
yeah and he was gone and we lost like
another six hours so we lost a full day
by day three of shooting which was not
the best and I'd know this at first but
by the time he got back we'd lost 12 and
a half hours something like that no now
here's a follow-up question did you guys
have to like hire an assistant for
someone to like wipe his ass for because
like how do you wipe your ass if you
have to Brian did buy him a present at
the end of that week to say it to say
sorry which was just to help him you
know pleasure himself
you got a little pocket Jesus I can't
imagine having two broken arms who wipes
your ass I mean like you're a glove man
or the funny thing is he likely did get
to that he was pretty I mean he came
back and start doing stunts even with
two broken arms okay so so it was never
that bad enough he Freddie
it was pretty painful but he toughed
through it but he fractured his right
his right left wrist and broke his right
elbow so his right arm was I think he's
left-handed
so his right arm was much in much worse
shape but he's good and it was was
better Oh some stuff any more question
but I'm sure you guys got a thousand
questions about the broken arm
how many question how many times did you
get asked a lot yeah to the point where
I started getting playfully dismissive
yeah did anybody else anybody else get
injured I said yeah but it's like the
NFL everybody's injured it's just some
of us talked about it and some of us
keep our injuries quiet my injuries
quiet cuz I don't want it to affect the
rest of the team you just start making
up nonsense here's what I wonder okay
you're filming working 12 to 16 hour
days will you crash it out or will you
what were you watching the kind of
decompress in Atlanta I was I don't
think I didn't you saw me I didn't do
anything I just worked so I would get
done we would get done after like a
12-hour day I go home and and start
breaking down the script again for the
next day I'd sleep like three to four
hours get up try to you know shake
myself awake I go and run sometimes in
the morning even though I was dead tired
just to get blood moving yeah
and but pretty much I didn't I had big
plans to take you guys all out
we're gonna go rafting on the on the
river we're gonna go to all these strip
clubs whatever and
just got bogged down I was so tired I
was so tired yeah did you end up firing
anybody yes yeah what happened nothing
bad I mean it's part of a process when
you're in long production and some
people sort of don't fit and it's
uncomfortable but you had somebody else
do so you have to mean how many people
were how many people total we're on
production and you know I don't know but
there probably had 150 150 yeah hundred
fifty somebody gotta go you know think
of all the employees at Walmart not
everybody staying onboard know it's job
it's true it's also like it's like a
weird summer camp you have to be around
all these people in like close proximity
under stress every day for like 12 14
hours and if someone's like even half an
[ __ ] you're like no we got I don't
like that guy's breath he's always in my
face and that breath he's got to go I
was uh you know it stresses me out on
sets was that is that knowing
everybody's name because there's so many
people and everybody that's weird my
name so cuz I need a guess then you
might get to deep where you ask people's
name like week three this person's been
touching your face
handing you down to make up people you
always little me okay are you making
strong icon eyedrops two point okay I
didn't know there was an exception for
makeup but well yeah makeup because you
every day but I some people is kind of
you not have it you in passing you know
what I mean
and so sets up the lights and [ __ ] yeah
yeah you they're cool but it is like all
[ __ ] week for you start looking at they
walk you talk to you sit might have
liked listening into [ __ ] just a
conversation no it's true I just I used
to pride myself like on TV knowing
everyone's name that was one of my
favorite things to do because a lot of
people busting their ass you want to
like be good too
yeah I sit in a chair like do this yeah
I think it should be over there that's
like my whole job this guy's runnin [ __ ]
upstairs sweating his ass yeah least he
can know his name is Brian
but like this movie was big and people
kept changing cuz you know you you have
swings coming in and out and it bugs me
I feel like an [ __ ] all because they
become like a family right they all
become one working UNIX a family and
they all expect you to treat them like
family yeah it's not everybody's gotta
be cool look they don't expect you when
it's nice what you do they expect you to
be an [ __ ] Louis expectations yeah
[ __ ] so so bad like Jon Hamm gotta be a
dick so then if you speak and know that
anything like you so nice like that's
all it took is just speaking but yes is
a people don't expect I've had it with
you people
I'll talk to somebody and get their name
and then it'll be ten minutes later and
I'll say alright nice to meet you such a
such you remember my name
it has been ten minutes but they give me
this curve they agree on his car that's
a huge thing that SNL poll show and
Scarlett Jo and Scarlett Johansson was
hanging out yeah and I just talked to
her for like maybe 5-10 minutes and then
when we were leaving she was just like
well nice to meet you Tony and I was
like that was the first time I seen
Scarlett in a minute and since they
probably 20 we had that joke and I had
seen this is that joke and then I felt
weird about that joke no I don't know
that joke with that joke I went to this
party and I had matter I wasn't I wasn't
really known but she I guess she was a
comedy fan and she saw a clip of mine
and so I met her at this pie cabin in
New York closed it's closed yeah yeah
yeah and she I end up talking she was
like oh I'm a big fan or you stand up
and I'm like oh [ __ ] Scarlett Johansson
so we talked for a little bit it's kind
of dry ass conversation cuz I'm hella
nervous yeah and somebody else ended up
talking to her and then I'm still hyped
about it and then I see I see her maybe
a few weeks later a couple months
whatever I see her the same club again
and then she was in live with a bad
throw
[Laughter]
I tell the story in my special [ __ ] so
then it was just that thing well oh I
haven't seen it since I did that joke on
a very public stage but she was cool
yeah well you're not making fun of her
that's what was making fun of myself
yeah that's all it takes like you said
to be cool to just remember somebody's
name yeah it's a huge thing I've noticed
because I think most directors are dicks
so like if you remember your best boy
grip snai m-- like it is like it's a you
should because that's a pretty guy high
up guy and the crew but like most people
don't get that I'm had like some you
know grown men really kind of like be
emotional with me and be like you're the
first director that's ever like three
weeks into the show my name like they
say you know they say your memory is
like a like a cup full of like water or
liquid and there's only so much you can
retain and it just starts overflowing
into a while so it's like names just
getting tossed in there just get
overflowed and it's almost like you you
can't expect famous people to remember
your name it's uh it took me meeting
like Dave Chappelle like ten times
before he remembered I don't even know
if he still remembers my name
yeah but like you know like I don't hold
it against him yeah there's something
you know so many people Pete so many
people know you it's like the other side
like I always remember there's like this
thing this like footage of Jack
Nicholson during the making of the
shining in this documentary that
Kubrick's daughter was shooting and it's
bad the scenes you know they're shooting
they're shining and then look like
there's a moment where like although I
don't know finance ears or executives
come and it's you know he's like tucks
it has to tuck in his shirt like shake a
bunch of people's hands cuz they're
paying for the movie and he I think he
doesn't remember their names just saying
it's nice to see you it's nice uni turns
the camera is like the average celebrity
meets like a thousand people a day yeah
you have to say nice to see you because
you have no idea who anyone is that cerb
yeah I'm okay
can't do it yeah I'm sure like if you
start if you're someone of importance
and that person is in the same room with
you
they're probably important somehow too
because they're in that room with you
yeah are we doing little you know
devices in my head China
Martin Martin Martin Martin so crazy
[Laughter]
negative Neutron Neutron Neutron Nancy I
got it and then because I feel like this
I really you can memorize things almost
instantly I remember I'd show you like a
page of jokes and like in in like a
split second you would memorize with all
those jokes and decide which ones you
pretty good memory most of which you do
[Laughter]
well yeah I kind of feel I mean
sometimes I'm wrong sometimes I don't
understand a joke or or why it's funny
it's been times I've done stuff in in
movies and television where I don't I
don't get this but I'll say that [ __ ]
I'll say it any when it comes out people
are like that was crazy and I was like
oh you like that cool yeah the little
tweaks you got brothers and sisters I
got a younger sister yeah younger sister
how much younger she's three and a half
years younger than me three and a half
years younger yep did y'all used to is
she in the arts at all she was a she was
a writer for a long time and now now she
just has like a job that makes me want
to kill herself a little bit but she's
like a corporate job it pays but now
she's a really funny she used to do
theater and stuff like that
did you have a direct her when you know
yeah that's all that's all I did yeah
[Laughter]
and she learned very quickly that like I
didn't have any other friends which is
why I was directing her
and stuff so she could blackmail me into
doing whatever she wants so she knew her
she knew her power as an actress oh wait
a second okay this offers in that great
[Laughter]
they're like 4 years old I wouldn't say
I'm the consummate pro about my podcast
but I look I took a little trip down
Jeff Tom said you to blame man that's a
couple things on there some music videos
on there oh yeah it's some questionable
stuff on there I need to clean that up
maybe a little bit music video what was
the name it was something vodka alchemy
vodka I don't oh yeah some old
commercials from ten years ago
oh used to direct commercials yeah yeah
okay okay
we're with the Polish joke oh yeah
alchemy vodka that was 2008 I was 2007
now is the beginning of YouTube yeah
first started yeah yeah did you find
Chocolate Rain Tay Zonday yeah you
directed it we did not the original one
we did a dr. pepper commercial with Tay
Zonday Oh like two thousand five or six
or something like that Wow called cherry
Chocolate Rain anything I wrote a new
song for Tay he still calls me every
every Christmas - what - wish me yeah
what was he like to work with oh he's a
great you know he's like a history
professor so he's super dried through
like you know he doesn't he has like a
thousand facts and said but you know he
talks like this
to do okay that sounds lovely I'll just
sort of walk but we did a whole you got
look at that I can't believe you didn't
find that but that was like I think the
first time like a YouTube guy had ever
been in a commercial and it's so dumb I
had like the Knicks City Dancers in it
dancing around him and okay how many
commercials have you done I don't know a
lot a lot not yeah I did
that's mostly what I did before I
started doing TV so that one's deep
though the one sometimes so you've done
commercials with athletes before I've
only done like I did a bunch of PGA
stuff so if you call golfers athletes
basketball players the producer or
whoever will come up to the director
back all right you got 20 minutes with
him that's it that's always what happens
yeah absolutely yep yep just give you an
unreasonably small amount of time back
you've got three and a half minutes get
it done the advertisement we're making
is longer the amount of time that's
physically impossible yeah like when I
shot with Durant years back yeah they
told the directors like yeah he gotta be
out in 30 something minute yeah [ __ ] I
gotta go to practice I just want to get
this done sell these shoes get these
couple shots of me I'm not about to do
this 20 times with you [ __ ]
if you bring this up cuz you're trying
to figure out how you do that as an
actor no I got 33 minutes of the
Hannibal trailer I won't be needing a
trailer
little ground somewhere else rel Howery
it's really that [ __ ] right there
well the commercials do they do they
hook it up though they usually have a
nice nice setup well it's nice because
you can make a decent amount of money
and it's it's quick you know that's a
weird thing about this movie and TV and
commercials like pretty much on TV it's
like three weeks I come in prep shoot a
couple episodes to a week at cutting
done this is like a year and a half a
movie is an emotional roller coaster man
it is it's a mirror in tears so yeah we
do a podcast DVD comment commentary
watch the movie so many times I got a
look at the airplane version and I can
look at the HB over h-dr with the HBO
version was it's a HBO like they it's
only 16:9 you know so they crop it oh
they won't do like we shot our
widescreen so gotta go back in and like
pan and scan the whole movie because
these were certain shots yeah it is
because you're just looking you start to
get a point where you'd not even watch
the movie er just looking for stuff but
you guys sit there for like 90 minutes
and then you hit something and then it
takes like 20 minutes to fix it so like
to do the pan that's game version of
movies like a full you sit in a room for
four hours now I'll be honest I sent the
editor to do that but when you're doing
the so when you when you guys decide
what goes into the trailer that must be
a [ __ ] process huh well it's it
the weird thing is is that the marking
Department sends a movie to like a bunch
of different trailer houses and they cut
versions of it and then they send them
to you and I don't see him until until
they got through like version 20 yeah
and then I dunno it's
and I sort of like said what if you take
this and put this here but you know and
add some stuff oh okay
and I think we were like to version 25
of that but yeah there's and they test
it they do like they put an audience in
front of it and they score it based on
what joke they like the most I mean it's
what you don't want to give you too much
right now
well I argued and argued about like
certain stuff being in there sort of you
know beginning of this wouldn't ed
Helmes like charges this stage yeah
which is sort of a moment that I don't
know if we should be giving away yeah
but yeah but the movie still works I've
seen it with audiences since the trailer
came out and they seem to still get way
into it like they they like cheered
during this moment and I thought for
sure that would get ruined by the
trailer but it's fine yeah okay new
segment what's your yeah three coveted
director moves move that you see other
directors do their signature in TV or
film where you say Tim that's dope like
style things or dial things that are
specific to a certain director this
might take me a minute it's okay we take
out the pocket [ __ ] thing for ready
you know one thing I'd love ever did you
ever see the remake of would of
mentoring candidate with Denzel and
Geoffrey right I see the movie yeah the
movie yeah yeah one that one thing I
love that Johnny the deme used to do is
have the actor talked directly into the
camera when they're talking to each
other it's so uncomfortable to watch
it's creepy as [ __ ] I don't know how to
use that in a comedy I try to steal
everything from her mother but yes if I
can because there's some cool I mean
it's not what they do it they are well
they do that the one that's like more
documentaries now I was gonna say they
do that with the office but they're not
talking to each other yeah with the
offices like there yeah they're talking
to the cameramen but this is this is in
the middle of the Commerce yeah super
weird but it's it's great he doesn't
sound some lancelot - yeah no other
directors do that it's all right sir I
don't know sort of his thing ice I love
how Spike Lee like flu come around
yeah the glides people around yeah how
did you feel about that movie Birdman I
like that movie did you dislike it Tony
yeah he was trying to bait you - I know
I could tell there's a lot of facial
expressions everything right now must
make you so angry
yeah just it it enraged me that movie
enraged me because they they they fooled
everyone into thinking that it was one
big shot and I sorry you alright
director you saw through that [ __ ] yeah
and it was just one big pretentious
piece of [ __ ] garbage that was
disguised as and this billion weeds
wouldn't be clicking [ __ ] [ __ ] that
movie no it's caught that movie it's
clearly cut up yeah I don't know why
this entirely cut up they could have
just not said that well it could have
not said that would you feel better
about it if they know it still sucked
[ __ ] that movie or anyway [ __ ] Birdman
[ __ ] it
I'm just saying come on man like a lot
like like there's there's like people
like David Lynch and Lars von Trier who
did that really well anyways it's like
okay that style has already been used
and the selling point of that movie was
it was just one big shot which was
[ __ ] and a director such as yourself
or or an experienced director the knows
right away I'm not even an experienced
director but I knew like this was
cheated yeah
but it just like it just had this like
pretentious vibe to it it just felt like
a bunch of whiney theater kids and then
you know like mathematic drums and the
new burden won all these awards I was
like [ __ ] this man that movie was so bad
the girl I was dating at the time we got
into a fight by the end of the movie
about how much yeah because I wanted to
leave because the movie was so bad and
she was like no we got to stick this do
you guys see how it ends and I was like
a quarter then how does it end I can't
remember in fly it's flying off you
don't really know was a terrible prequel
to that cross man Birdman was dope you
just got it I never even thought about
the connection between homecoming and
Birdman that is super weird
why not everything about that I think I
got the connection from somebody on the
internet that said it I didn't create
that myself here's my director move
because I think yeah I think I would
like directing just because it is I mean
it's a lot of work but you always got
some [ __ ] to do which is what I
appreciate it when I have my TV show
where I had to deal with casting
costumes right too much downtime in the
acting yes too much doubt Simon
just sit around he's words say the words
Sam a few times and it's back to
downtown mentally you stay and then you
get to learn about a bunch of a
different stuff and have different
interactions and get information if
you're asked to write questions my
directed move is to uh you know do
establishing exterior shots establish an
exterior hospital you showed a hospital
shot uh-huh but then next scene it's
just in a house why would you do that
because it's my style artist writing the
script but that was the whole the whole
premise theory a gas station okay
actually a grocery store but that's
that's my main directing choice that's
what I'm gonna build my brand off yeah
that's a better answer I gotta come up
with a better answer than my three
directors my I think that my directing
style would be like a straight-up
dictatorship like I think I would be
like like Kim Jong Oh
oh you said I'd be like you shut up
you get over you do this you shut up
again like that I think that that's my
you know I'd I'd be my directing stocks
I'm I'm like a control freak
like that like especially if there's
like if time is money and I got a
[ __ ] move and get [ __ ] done
I think I think that uh I would drive my
cast my cast crazy I think I would drive
everyone nuts but then I think you
didn't initially bill that would you be
that character right away on your first
project or what you build into that I'd
probably be that right away my goal is
to build into him how do you get people
to work with you again cuz then you
gonna see you don't have to call is that
a product is dope
really because so so you see that's the
thing because sometimes confidence
confidence confidence confidence like if
confidence is that energy and people
will receive it with osmosis no I'm I'm
talking to a [ __ ] established
director right now so I sound like an
[ __ ] but I'm just saying that's how I
see that's how I would see myself is
being that guy and just being extremely
confident just trust it and if it comes
out like [ __ ] then I find another career
you know I mean what's your vision oh
you you just talk about more of a style
I won't make a movie that's not like
Birdman that's what I would do a movie
that's more shot one shot I would do
like a million shots yeah many shots as
possible
ya know long so no long shots
it'd be like a it'd be like a mosaic
more than a film and you know what else
you know what else is not a long shot
tag in theatres June 15th guaranteed to
be the number two comedy number two you
know cuz they gonna have to no matter
what it does they're gonna figure out
words to spin it great they gonna make
it sound good the number one comedy with
people instead of cartoons of 2018 what
there hasn't really been like a [ __ ]
outstanding comedy until this movie so
I'm very excited to see it I kept
telling him I feel like it's gonna be
the breakout comedy of the year yeah
there hasn't been anything really that
dope till now I mean with the time to
attack and the podcast combining forces
it's unstoppable
yeah and with many shots and you got a
good chance many shots we got plenty of
shots we got a podcast manic drums no
[ __ ] theater kids bitching about dumb
[ __ ]
how how much the MC damnit sorry
how much did out
now other than Kato speaks ketose Deus
I'm getting tired of hearing that song
though and thought it's on every one of
these things trailers more expensive
because advertising yeah cuz like 30 is
what it costs just to play a song
briefly in my Netflix special that's
what the standard will be to play next
movie dog if you want that discounted
[ __ ]
[Music]
his Tomatoes all I said Jeff I know you
got to get out of here man thanks for
doing the show yeah thanks for having me
guys excited working with you I'm
excited for this project to finally be
out it was a fun time thanks Ann came
together well watching it with a crowd
was really exciting I'm proud of you
fellas man you guys did it I can't tell
you how much it means to me that he's in
this movie and even more than he's
excited about it I'm excited man oh
really
they have in the movie so I'm psyched
and congratulations on your debut man
thanks that's a big deal
that's a big [ __ ] deal yes awaited
tomorrow black black yep yeah go classy
cool what about you doing soup yep
seersucker seersucker foot after party
after party I got a blue suit oh yeah
you were telling me oh it's gonna be
good
blue got a skinny tie what about the guy
pushing the generator in the theremin
I'm wearing a sleeveless tuck I would
shorten run LeBron is my man thank you
sir
[Music]
[Music]